liquid is not really a suburb anymore
it's a particular kind of urban place
that looks suburban superficially but
which is netted fully into an urban
fabric hi I'm Matt wells for recent TV
and I'm here today with the Emmitt
Southern California writer thinker
historian DJ wall D famously of a holy
land the acclaimed about Lake with work
we're sitting right now DJ thank you
very much thank you
today very kind words most people know
you through Holy Land through your
blogging at KCET and riding in the LA
Times and elsewhere but you have also
been for decades working for the city of
lakewood where I at once worked briefly
as a teenager Lakewood is a contract
city one of the first or one of the few
contract cities out there can you tell
us a little bit about the history of
that concept how it has applied to the
development of Lakewood and how Lakewood
is different than cities around it
no interestingly enough liquid was the
very first city in the nation to
contract from most of its municipal
services from other sources initially
that other source was the County of Los
Angeles but in the decades following
1954 when Lakewood incorporated we
branched out to provide services under
contract with the county like our
Sheriff's Department services with
private industry like trash collection
and street sweeping services with other
public entities other consortia for
example our animal control service is
done by a consortium of cities that
banded together to provide animal
control services and some services are
conducted in-house like the one you used
to work for which is our Park Department
which originally was a standalone
special district but in 1957 was folded
into the city of liquid as our
Recreation Department now in 54 this was
a radically different idea no city in
America had incorporated on that basis
but in the years following the success
of Lakewood led to lots of in
corporations of cities that are like
liquid in contracting for all or most of
their municipal services so they're
about 40 cities in LA County that are
contract cities and there are about a
hundred and forty cities in the
state of California about the 480 cities
there are also contract cities and then
some unknown number because we don't
track every detail of this some unknown
number of contract cities around the
nation and how has that affected the
development of the city its political
culture or its governance culture or how
or just you know the results well
compared to other places around I mean
the obvious one is that we're a city of
about eighty three thousand persons
about nine point five square miles I
mean kind of roughly the same size as
Santa Monica for example but our
workforce is tiny by comparison we only
have about a hundred and seventy city
employees our city staff at City Hall is
very small you know Santa Monica's or
similar cities well because they have
their own put their own Police
Department they have a much larger work
force in the several hundreds of
employees so contracting allowed us to
be very lean in terms of our overhead
and to be very flexible because we can
contract with one entity when it's
providing the best kind of service and
then change our minds in contact with
someone else in the future some other
way but very difficult to change the
dynamics of a city service provision
model if you have regular full-time
benefited unionized employees who are
providing those services and how has
Lakewood come through you know the
recent long-standing at this point
unpleasantness in California in terms of
local governments the state governments
and etc well we've been very lucky for a
long time
but small cities like liquid can't be
lucky always or forever and so we're
we're suffering like other cities are
through a very difficult economic period
with diminished sales at our major
shopping mall with families living from
paycheck to paycheck with an unfortunate
number of foreclosed properties the
saving grace for liquid in the face of
all of that has been a very
conservatively run City specifically a
city's pinched every penny it it can for
decades and decades correct me if I'm
wrong but Lakewood and the sort of the
long beach air
were in was basically the Levittown of
the west coast this how many thousands
of houses were built and how few days
empty farmland in 1949 purchased by
three developers construction began in
late 1949 seventeen thousand five
hundred houses built in less than three
years so we had an instant City in the
form of liquid but of course it wasn't
actually a city it was unincorporated
County territory
it took political will and a part of
residents in the years following the
completion of the building of the houses
to turn this immense tract of
residential suburban Los Angeles into a
real city and in 1954 Lakewood became a
city through that contract plan we
discussed earlier now that this area was
dependent certainly through the late 80s
on aerospace you have a book coming out
next year called blue sky architecture
that metropolis about aerospace yeah and
I saw a piece that you wrote recently
for a KCET sort of lamenting the the
fall of a period where you could
graduate from high school get a job in
McDonnell Douglas have good benefits and
a decent salary and raise your kids and
then go play at Hartwell park and
everyone would win that period is over
and yet the the economy isn't devastated
what what's your take on how things have
evolved from there and and are we are we
nostalgic for a time that was as good as
it as it seems in the rearview mirror
let's say well I am NOT a nostalgia
stand I'm not nostalgic for the past but
indeed a realist many forces combined at
the end of the Second World War to
situate a immense economy of aerospace
production in Southern California one of
the Centers of that was the Douglas
Aircraft plant just a hardly more than
three miles of where we're sitting right
now and that plant at that time using
that technology is available that
employed 50 60 thousand men mostly men
in in in the workforce
well that represented one out of every
ten jobs in lakewood for years and years
and years
Douglas is gone boeing took over the
companies
years ago bowling is nearly gone was
virtually no production left at the old
Douglas plant except some assembly for
the c-17 military transport plane which
is the last aircraft being built in
Southern California it'll be amazing
it'll be the very last major aircraft
built in Southern California aerospace
continues defense related manufacturing
high-tech elements of the aerospace
environment will continue but we don't
make planes in Southern California
anymore don't make planes at the
doorstep of liquid any longer and that
has had enormous impacts on on jobs and
lifestyles in the region a lot of people
received your book holyland in the mid
90s as a kind of Defense of Suburbia or
a defense of the idea that suburbia is a
lot less cookie-cutter than most people
realize even though what there was three
models of homes although more than that
but basically yeah 3-bedroom 2bath and
we both could draw it on the walls right
here now that that holy land has been
kind of received and and you yourself
have kind of gone into the graduation of
letters and have a national reputation
certainly you see the cultural forces
which are still kind of against suburbia
how do you kind of square or how do you
how do you retake that pulse in the year
2011 do you still find suburbia
interesting are you becoming more of a
pusher of urbanized kind of new urbanism
because of it let me just say that I'm a
partisan of suburban places I see in
them the values of that I've been
incorporated in my life I see in them
the values have been incorporated in the
lives of tens of thousands of people in
Southern California in in Lakewood
specifically on the other hand I also
understand the uniqueness of urban
development in Southern California in
the LA area the liquid is not really a
suburb anymore it's a particular kind of
urban place that looks suburban
superficially but but which is netted
fully into an urban fabric California
has always been an optimistic place
people come here last decade not coming
here as much as the first time I think
in our
history where population growth was the
same as it was countrywide
is it looking around at the political
culture at the fiscal crisis and just
the population growth numbers is
something changing kind of irrevocably
and and is optimism going out the window
with them
I hope optimism isn't California
Southern California was a great
attractor in the period from 1945 onward
because here was located industries that
were grew every decade and now those
industries are gone how do we replace
that what makes Southern California a
Great Attractor still well the weather
didn't go away the beaches didn't go
away the feeling people have about
Southern California didn't go away but I
agree with you that's a lot of the
optimism has has drained out of of
everyday life for working-class people
in Southern California and we need to
find ways in which though that optimism
can be restored well here's hoping that
the renewal happens sometime soon
thank you very much DJ Waldie for recent
TV I am that wealth
you